hello very good morning to you richie
sunak and liz truss have clashed over
how best to fend off recession following
a stark warning from the bank of england
that the economy will begin to shrink
later this year with inflation set to
top 13 percent
the tory leadership hopefuls went
head-to-head on a special sky news
program the battle for number 10.
responding to a question from an
audience member the foreign secretary
said a recession is not inevitable but
the former chancellor warned that his
rival's plans to cut tax could make the
situation worse
our political correspondent ali
fortescue reports
a decisive moment in the race to be the
next prime minister arriving as ballots
land on tory doorsteps
liz trusts the undisputed front runner
hey charlie you're right rishi sunax
struggling to close the gap
tails never fails do you want to go
first or second i want to go first
please there we go an early victory for
the foreign secretary but under the
studio spotlight with more than 60
mostly undecided party members the tough
questions began the bank of england have
said that a recession is inevitable
what could you do to mitigate the impact
of this
well what the bank of england have said
today is of course extremely worrying
but it is not inevitable
we can change the outcome and we can
make it more likely that the economy
grows and on the foreign secretary's
first big stumble this week on public
sector pay an admission but no apology
liz why did you announce a
well-researched and fully costed policy
in which you openly said you valued the
work of teachers nurses and police
officers in newcastle where i work
less than you value those in guilford
for example why should we trust your
judgment immediately as there were
concerns expressed about this policy
i said we're not going ahead with it
and from policy to personality quickfire
questions no politician wants to
misjudge uh what's the naughtiest thing
you've ever done i'm certainly i'm
certainly not going to say that on tv oh
was it that naughty
well my daughters are watching so i
don't want them i don't want them
is there anything that you feel that you
would want to come clean with the
audience here in the studio and at home
because there's no one else listening so
it's all fine i can just tell anything
that you need to get off your chest
i can tell you okay there are no
skeletons in my closet
liz truss wants to be seen as a
candidate to change the course her own
path though hasn't run straight
you were a remainer
and now you're not you supported brits
to fight in ukraine then you didn't you
wanted to build on the green belt and
now you don't you wanted to abolish the
monarchy and now you don't you wanted to
arm taiwan and now i'm not sure if
you're saying whether you do or not you
wanted civilization so we do provide
okay with those you wanted to cut civil
servants pay in the regions and then you
said you didn't
will the
real
liz trust please stand up
okay yes you know i have i have you know
developed my views i've considered
things differently and i also listen to
people okay and i think that's important
then came the turn of the former
chancellor
is there a point that you would stand
aside in this campaign the quick answer
is no
and that's because well thank you
and rishi sunak hasn't been forgiven by
many in the party for turning on boris
johnson you unite in boris for your own
interest
right it's simply impossible for a
chancellor and prime minister not to be
on the same page when it comes to
economic policy you've been campaigning
for a long time
and it was perfectly timed a cynical
motivation to try and get you into
number 10. no that's just
simply not true so i was due to give a
speech with the prime minister the next
week and in the conversations about
putting that speech together on the
economy it was clear our differences
were too big to reconcile okay so that
was the reason plus i think let's not
look at the hit the bars with rose
tinted spectacles here everyone
remembers what was going on with chris
pincher
how will you balance the need to address
the escalating cost of living crisis
particularly for those that are on lower
incomes
alongside the need to keep the economy
in good order the lights on the economy
are flashing red and the root cause is
inflation
and then from economics to a rare test
on foreign policy on the conflict in
ukraine boris johnson has um
really thrown himself into the cause i
think everybody might agree with that
he's regarded as a hero apparently in
ukraine that's what he tells us he
brandishes his missile launches we've
seen that are you really
tough enough to stand up
to vladimir putin
yes i'm tough enough and i'm already
delivering the measures that are
actually causing him the most trouble
thank you
the applause kept coming for rishi
sooner people feel
that you can't walk a mile in their
shoes because you're walking in your
prada shoes what would you say to them
i think the british people judge people
by their character and by their actions
not by their bank account
the ballots will decide the next pm last
night just a show of hands it looks to
me as though mr tsunak convinced you far
more than miss trust he may have won the
room but this is still a divided party i
think i'm going to go with uh liz truss
um i think that she did a pretty good
debate i came here intending to vote for
liz trust
barring anything major and nothing
happened to dissuade me i'm very
confident in my vocalist trust i think
i'd be very
doing that his answers
at some point when he was asked to be
short were short he was clear he was
concise rishi sunak delivered on detail
but not the knockout blow he needed
voting's underway and it is the foreign
secretary who remains on course for
downing street ali fortescue sky news
well let's get some analysis and
reaction to last night's programme uh
the conservative peer and pollster lord
robert hayward is here with me a very
good morning to you
going into the show last night rishi
sunak needed a big performance didn't he
the polls were not in his favor so did
he manage to to pull off a big moment
big is possibly a slight exaggeration
but there's no question in my mind and
the vote of the audience it was the
first time that he had clearly led in a
debate and
kate got the audience to vote and there
was no question she described it as a
clear majority for rishi well that's
interesting and liz trust similarly went
in needing at least a safe performance
she didn't want to shift the dial at all
so did she manage that oh there's no
question she she did she's improved from
the first debate where she appeared
incredibly wooden and got the lowest
ratings she's improved enormously comes
across well but the issue that dominated
last night was inevitably the bank of
england report the increase in interest
rates and that played two rishi's
strengths and i think that's probably
what impacted on the audience that's
interesting that you say that because
some people might say well we associate
rishi sunak with being in charge of the
economy for the last two years you might
argue that it would count against him
yes i thought that he would have some
difficulty on in that field
but there was a sense which was conveyed
in the audience and their reaction uh
both on that issue and on others that he
had a grasp almost as steady as she goes
rather than let's not take a risk at
this point uh and it was it was markedly
different from previous debates and were
there any particular moments
for good or for bad that will stick with
the people who are voting for these two
leaders i think
liz has the problem it came up in a
question from the audience and then was
repeated as part of the series of pro of
questions to uh liz about things she
changed her mind on and that is this
pay for people in the north and the
midlands in terms of being a nurse or a
policeman
and i think that's going to keep coming
back because she wasn't willing to say
it was a mistake what she said was it
was interpreted incorrectly
in other words it's other people's fault
and that didn't resonate well with the
audience well yeah she was challenged
quite hard on that wasn't she by k
burley
do you feel that she didn't give an
adequate response then because she just
did say we're not going ahead with this
so why do you keep asking me about it
i'm judging the reaction of the audience
rather than my own perception and i just
listening and
watching the audience reaction one just
felt uh that she didn't deal with it in
the same way that um
one might have done and in the same way
why do you think that rishi soon acted
particularly well last night was it
solely because there was such a focus on
the economy because of the day's news i
wouldn't say it's particularly well but
he did better than liz and i think
there's a sense that this was the first
time he'd actually got the better of him
and it was what one might describe as
the wild forecast of 13
inflation and a recession and all these
sorts of things
that he could as you asked just now have
been in difficulty but there was a sense
that he conveyed the message better so
that the message was got across by by
rishi in a way that it hasn't been
previously and yet there's a sense of
optimism coming from liz trust isn't
there she was keen to point out when
asked about the bank of england's
predictions she said recession isn't
inevitable
that there is the possibility to turn
things around i mean is that something
that people want to hear they want to to
feel that there could be a better way i
think
until yesterday with the bank of england
and
it's pretty dire forecasts
there was probably a sense that the
population at large was willing to go
down the path of well there is an
alternative
but i think the messaging yesterday and
it's been coming from the european
central bank from the fed in the united
states is the world the free world is in
a difficult set of circumstances
and somebody who
with confidence can answer the questions
as rishi appeared to and as one of the
audience said on that clip briefly
succinctly summarize where we are i
think that was persuasive
and last time you came on this show you
talked about the impact that programs
like this can have that debates and
interviews
big interviews with the candidates can
make on the end result
do you feel that things have changed how
what kind of impact do you think they've
made liz has had the best of the last
few days no question about it with the
series of endorsements from different
major personalities i think what
happened last night was there was a stop
in terms of
um the the momentum in one direction it
won't necessarily reversed it but there
is there will be this morning a
different sense of messaging
um that is around um the first question
to rishi was it's inevitable you're
going to lose why don't you withdraw
and i think probably
by the end of that session
one understood why he's not withdrawing
because he had actually got some of his
messaging across but liz has done well
in the previous few days and it's
interesting timing isn't it because i
think the ballots are arriving some of
the people in the audience had had them
some hadn't most hadn't but it's
crucial timing at the moment oh
absolutely and to that extent that has
worked in rishi's favor because the
momentum was with liz no question about
it and had the ballots arrived a few
days earlier people would have completed
them i haven't received mine uh people
i've been speaking to yesterday evening
haven't received theirs so it is
absolutely crucial and we keep talking
about this poll lead that liz truss has
rishi sunak's supporters would say
that's not what we're witnessing
when we go out and about we're
witnessing much more support than is
reflected in the polls i mean what's
your sense of what's going on my sense
is that the polls are right up to a
point
but
you had the audience response last night
and remembering that they were an
audience from all over the country
so
there have been a lot of undecideds
and i think you may have got a fair
amount of them or them reflected in the
audience last night all the polls
although the number of undecideds has
been diminishing
um i think the audience last night
conveyed a message from the undecideds
largely
lord robert hayward always very
interesting to get your take on things
thanks so much for coming in this
morning we appreciate it
so we did speak to some of the tory
party members in crew who were undecided
at the start of the program to gauge
whether anything that was said by the
two candidates had won them over so who
was most in touch with the needs of the
north was a key issue for them and it
did seem that liz trust came out on top
so let's listen to their views
we actually want leveling up to no
longer just be a term and actually be a
real thing and i think liz trust is
leaning towards more
honesty about actually i'm going to do x
y and z to make your life easier it is a
real difficult one here it is really
difficult and
you know i suppose i am swaying towards
liz she
was educated in the north she's
much more in touch with what northern
voters hold dear than rishi
i would definitely be leading to islay's
trust yeah definitely
well let's bring in our political
correspondent uh rapal so we have from
some of the tory members in crew largely
backing liz truss after last night's
programme but the audience there backing
rishi sunag is he gaining though a bit
of momentum do you think it feels like
what was happening there is mirroring
what rishi sunat's campaign team have
been saying for the last week as these
big name endorsements have come out in
favor of liz trust and the polls have
generally been pointing in massively in
favor of liz trust as well they are
saying look the people that we are
talking to on the ground we feel like we
are winning people around and we are
persuading um people and the strategy
for the last week from rishi sunak has
been that there have been fewer sort of
big media appearances um and more of
kind of going around to associations
last weekend i think he was at six
associations in one day trying to talk
to as many conservative voters as
possible and persuade them and win them
round the big unknown is whether he can
do that to the extent that he can change
so many minds through programs like the
sky news debate last night through
constituency visits that he can start to
sort of fight against the the kind of
overwhelming almost tory instinct at the
moment that seems to be going towards
liz trust now
the second thing i think that will be
interesting to see how it plays into
this is these dire warnings that have
come out from the bank of england um
yesterday about spending the much of
next year in recession about where
inflation and where interest rates um
are going to go and i think the point
that lord hayward was making there is
very interesting whether people put that
together with the pitches from liz trust
and rishi sunac that are very very
different there is a definite choice
here and whether they decide that
actually given those dire um pretty
fragile circumstances they want to go
for someone that maybe has the
experience in the treasury and that is
coming across maybe as a bit more
sensible a bit more steady as she goes
and not take the risk with liz trust or
does that sort of instinct hold that we
want to try something new we want to
roll the dice i think at the moment
that's unclear i don't think there was
any disasters or absolute triumphs from
the debate last night that will shift
the dial to the point of you know
putting rishi sunak back level instantly
but i think over the coming days how
those performances last night and the
backdrop of the bank of england warnings
combine will be interesting to see
whether liz trust can pick can keep that
momentum that she's generated over the
last week or whether his ballots start
to drop rishi sunak is able to change
minds quietly in the background and sort
of get people to come around to his way
of thinking
especially because of the really really
worrying year that we've all got ahead
of us yeah that that potentially changes
things doesn't it let's see rob for a
moment thanks very much indeed
so do stay with us still to come on the
show i'm going to be speaking to the
business secretary and liz trust
supporter quasi quatting after that
stark economic warning that rob was just
talking about
from the bank of england
and the former international trade
secretary and rishi sunak supporter dr
liam fox will be with me soon after
eight o'clock
and the shadow work and pension
secretary jonathan ashworth will be with
me for labor
[Music]
so yesterday saw the biggest rise in
interest rates for 27 years and a
warning from the governor of the bank of
england that we're in for a long
recession
so there was a prediction that inflation
could rise as high as 13.3 percent
largely as a result of rising energy
prices now to counter that the base rate
of interest has been raised to 1.75
now that's an increase of half of a
percentage point the reality is the uk
could experience five consecutive
quarters of recession that's equivalent
to 15 months from the final quarter of
this year and the gdp could fall by as
much as 2.1 percent from its peak
well speaking to sky news the governor
of the bank of england explained why
they're raising interest rates
well ashley nag joins me now from a high
street in south london so a big jump in
interest rates at a time when people are
struggling with the cost of living
economists are predicting that the price
cap could rise to 3
500 pounds a year for people which is a
staggering figure that for so many
people across the uk is simply going to
be unaffordable not only are people at
the moment struggling to pay their phone
bills but they're struggling to fill up
their cars not to mention the spiraling
energy cross that we're also seeing on
top of this if you take this high street
for example all of those costs do
radiate down into places like this on
this particular high street you've got a
fish and chip shop next to a cafe next
to a fish mongers and all of those
businesses independently are going to
struggle with this cost of living if we
take the fish and chip shop for example
we look at their stock if the cost of
their batter or their fish goes up that
cost has to go somewhere even if it's
going up incrementally only by a few
pence that is translated down to the
consumer and people are therefore going
to be spending less because of rising
costs elsewhere and we know though that
one of the biggest dividing lines in
this leadership contest is tax cuts liz
trust said yesterday the recession she
didn't think was inevitable despite what
the bank of england has been saying she
said that she would
cut taxes as soon as she got into office
from day one leading some to question
whether that would ramp up borrowing on
the other hand you've got russia sunak
who former chancellor up until three
weeks ago and wasn't that chancellor's
hot seat in charge of the public purse
up until three weeks ago and was in
charge of it for two
years now he said that that's not the
answer to do that immediately to cut
back costs on taxes what she suggested
is cutting vat off energy bills yes that
would benefit
people in the short term but long term
is what people are really going to be
caring about it's
no secret that people are struggling not
only to pay their household bills but
also with the amount of money they have
at their disposal to spend on
materialistic things but things that
people need to keep themselves going
there's no doubt anna that the cost of
living crisis is going to be an
unavoidable issue in this contest
indeed ashley thanks very much indeed
for
that let's take a look at some of the
day's other headlines now and the
parents of archie battersby are expected
to find out this morning if they can
move their son out of a london hospital
and into a hospice their plea to let him
die with dignity comes after a series of
courts sided with doctors saying that
his life support treatment should be
switched off the twelve-year-old has
been in a coma since april
sakisthama has been found to have
breached the mp's code of conduct eight
times the parliamentary standards
commissioner says the labour leader
failed to register interests on time
including gifts from sports teams and
the sale of a plot of land but she adds
that these breaches are minor and there
was no deliberate attempt to mislead
more workers will join nationwide rail
strikes later this month unite says its
members working for network rail as
electric control room operators will
join other unions in taking action on
the 18th and 20th of august another
strike is planned on the 19th of august
by rmt workers on london underground
president biden has described the
sentencing of u.s basketball star
brittany greiner as unacceptable the 31
year old has been convicted of drug
possession and smuggling in russia and
sentenced to nine years in jail after
police found cannabis oil in her luggage
a prisoner swap was proposed which could
have resulted in greiner's release but
it was refused by russia
police have witnessed the id released
the identities of four vietnamese
nationals who were believed to have been
in a mill when it caught fire
specialist officers began searching the
mill in greater manchester after human
remains were found by demolition workers
last month following a blaze two months
ago
a host pipe ban is coming into force in
hampshire and the isle of wight today
after one of the driest years on record
and ahead of another predicted heat wave
the hosepipe ban in hampshire and the
isle of wight is the first in the area
since 2012. there's already one in place
on the isle of man
and one is due to come in next friday in
kent and sussex
plus at least two other water companies
are warning they may have to bring
restrictions in affecting areas
including
london surrey and devon
state employees in many parts of iraq
have been given a day off work as
temperatures rise to above 50 degrees in
several areas the heat has seen at least
10 provinces suspend work for most state
employees as the heat wave in the
country has been ongoing since mid-july
and is forecast to continue
meanwhile in germany repeated explosions
at an ammunition storage site prevented
firefighters from reaching a forest fire
in berlin around 100 firefighters
attended the fire but were unable to get
within a thousand meters of the flames
because of a series of explosions
triggered by the heat
so with parts of the world experiencing
extreme weather conditions let's take a
look shall we at the impact of climate
change on the planet and take a look at
our data dashboard on the right-hand
side you would normally see uh how our
power mix is made up how uk's power is
currently being produced those figures
not feeding in at the moment we'll try
and get that sorted for you but let's
take a look in the meantime at how much
warmer the earth is now than around the
time of the industrial revolution that's
1880 when records began and as you can
see that number currently is 1.2
to 3 degrees 24 degrees and that's the
state of global warming but that number
is ticking up and at the bottom
left-hand corner is the total number of
co2 emissions in millions of tons
now taiwan's premiere has condemned
chinese live-fire military drills taking
place around the island this week the
drills follow the visit to taiwan of
high-profile american politician nancy
pelosi which china has called a
provocative act
beijing has defended the missile
launches while the united states has
appealed for calm
well joining me now is the international
editor at taiwan plus divia gopalan um
so get us up to date with the very
latest state of play in the aftermath of
nancy pelosi's visit divya and
what kind of reaction have we had from
china
well that's right here in taiwan people
are watching these developments very
closely and the ministry of defense have
sent out warnings as a number of
missiles from china have actually
crossed over taiwan they said they were
monitoring those closely as it did not
actually was not going to land on taiwan
territory or waters and said what it did
was land in
japan's uh economic zone which japan has
lodged a complaint against beijing that
those waters are seen as part of tokyo's
so uh this is seen as something that's
not just for that affects taiwan it is
something that will have repercussions
in the region now the ministry of
defense has said that they are preparing
for war but they will not instigate a
conflict they do not want war they're
closely monitoring the enemy situation
that's language normally used when uh
other foreign forces which are beach
territorial lines have defied warnings
that call china highly provocative so
what does that mean for people on the
ground here well if you walk around the
streets of taiwan it seems like business
as usual but people are actually quite
nervous they're used to this kind of
language from china they're used to this
kind of provocation but they say not to
this scale not to the scale where the
main island has virtually been
surrounded flights have been disrupted
shipping routes disrupted and people we
spoke to here say that they are there is
a sense of worry and anxiety uh and if
it's any indication the most downloaded
app at the moment is the app that shows
you where the closest air raid shelters
and bunkers are to your location and the
capital so there is that sense that
people are feeling that they need to
have uh monitor what's happening
carefully and be prepared
the
thanks very much indeed
now let's get some more reaction to last
night's special sky news leadership
programme rishi sunak and liz trust
clashed over the economy after that
stark warning of spiraling inflation
from the bank of england so let's get
the reaction then of the business and
energy secretary and list trust
supporter quasi quatting a very good
result very good morning good to see you
so let's start with that bank of england
prediction that we heard yesterday
they said that households are going to
suffer their biggest squeeze on income
on record the economy is going to suffer
a year-long recession and some and
inflation is going to hit 13.3
this year
could this have been managed differently
i think the problem we have is very
simple
i think we've got uh inflation which is
as you say squeezing people's incomes
but we've also got a rising tax burden
and that's why i'm supporting list trust
i've never understood why if we're going
to
help people how we're going to help
people by putting up their taxes
especially when their daily shop their
costs
are going up and what's very clear to me
from what the bank of england said
yesterday is that more of the same just
simply carrying on with our economic
policy at the moment
is not going to cut it it's not going to
help us get out
of this difficulty and actually the imf
only 10 days ago
predicted that we would be the lowest
growth g7 economy
we can't tax ourselves
to growth and that's everyone
understands that everyone around the
world nobody's saying we're going to
help our people by putting up taxes
because that's what we're doing in this
country so it's interesting that you're
putting the blame on rishi sunax tax
rises
and yet the bank of england were
explicit about where the rise in
inflation came from they say it's rising
energy prices they largely blame the
actions of russia for our economic
problems so is it fair to blame richie
i'm not blaming the tax rises but
put very simply
you've got a world where prices are
going up so people's shop people's
energy bills are all going up so that
means their real incomes are being
squeezed
now to say to people your real incomes
are being squeezed and i'm going to put
your taxes up i think it's just adding
insult to injury you're not actually
dealing with the problem the way to deal
with the problem is to have a slightly
looser fiscal approach and that's what
rishi himself implied yesterday he said
he would help people now if you're going
to help people and have an intervention
that is a looser approach than simply
hiking up taxes to a 70-year high which
is where we are today okay and i want to
come on to
what we do about it in the future and
what could be done for the for the
poorer people but i do want to get to
the bottom of
why we've got to where we are now i mean
what do you think of how the bank of
england has handled this do you feel
that they should have raised interest
rates earlier so there is an argument
and i think it's a strong one to say
that uh inflation was an issue that was
identified
at the beginning of last year and in
fact i think
people bank of england commentators uh
even people in the treasury were saying
that this was an issue and the job of
the bank was to deal with the inflation
they've got a two percent inflation
target that's actually their mandate um
and now inflation is hitting double
digits so clearly something's gone wrong
and i think there is an argument to
suggest that rates should have probably
gone up uh slightly sooner so is the
bank of england fit for purpose i think
look to say that it's not fit for
purpose i think is is wrong i think it's
a a good institution i think it's worked
well uh but we need to look again
at what the mandate is and how best they
can actually fulfill that mandate what
does that mean well that means that if
your your target is two percent and
you're predicting 13
uh something's gone wrong and you've got
to look at how uh the bank is is is
organized and what the what the targets
are
will it keep its independence under a
liz trusts i think it's absolutely gonna
keep its independence but so how would
it change how do you have a target anna
if you have a target that's two percent
and you're predicting 13
something's gone wrong something's gone
wrong it's a hugely missed target you've
missed your two percent and that's not
because of global factors like there
were lots of global factors but people
have been talking about inflation for
the last two years and i think there is
an issue about how uh the bank uh is
operating because clearly if you've got
a if i say to you two percent is your
target and you say to me well actually
the time the uh it's going to hit 13 i
would quite rightly say something's gone
wrong we've got to look at how uh you're
performing so something has gone wrong i
mean this is a an economic crisis isn't
it i think it's a global crisis
compounded of two things firstly of
course we have the covid pandemic large
parts of the world the advanced
economies were shut down and then all of
a sudden they opened and there was huge
amounts of demand and the supply
couldn't keep up with it so that forced
prices up and then on top of that you've
got the russia
ukraine crisis which actually had a
knock-on effect on energy prices because
russia essentially is turning off its
gas supply to western europe so those
two factors have give put a lot of
pressure in the system and rishi was
right it's not it's the tax risers
themselves yeah didn't cause this but to
have tax rises in this context i think
is is is is very odd okay so an economic
crisis then so where's the chancellor uh
the chancellor checker is always uh
available uh and he's someone who didn't
hear from him yesterday this grim
warning from the bank of england i mean
is he on holiday um i'm in contact with
him i've just uh spoken to him well
what's up this morning he's completely
abreast of what's going on i'm the
business secretary i'm here i'm in your
studio i'm in a suit
i'm not i'm not on holiday
and we're absolutely focused on trying
to deal with this problem where's the
prime minister as well i mean some
people might be saying we've had this
terrible outlook for our economy there
are a lot of people who are suffering
right now not to mention in the future
we thought we might see our leaders at a
time like this well i'm the business
secretary i'm here um i'm in regular
contact with prime minister and
chancellor they're completely on top of
what's happening let's take a look then
how individuals are coping with this we
heard yesterday that the energy price
caps going to be reviewed every three
months and every six months
do you welcome that or do you worry at
all about individuals will now see
prices rise in october and january at a
time when they they want to be able to
keep the heating on i think it's a real
problem um and i'm sure that a future
chancellor
and the future prime minister whoever he
or she is uh will will address this very
very quickly um the reason
for having three month reviews is that
with six month reviews you have very
steep uh increases and that was uh very
very damaging as well but clearly
there's a there's an energy problem i
mean all over europe they're rationing
gas they've got to reduce their gas
consumption by 15 we're not doing that
in the uk but it's an issue that has to
be addressed and rishi himself uh i
thought very rightly said we're going to
have to intervene so even uh he who's
saying that we've got to keep taxes high
suggests and understands that there has
to be some more help to support people
okay well let's talk about what less
trust will do to support people rather
than rishi sunag last night she was
given a specific question about a
woman's um situation a woman called
selena earning just over 10 000 pounds a
year
she's not going to benefit from the
the scrapping the rise in the national
insurance that liz trust is promising
and the green energy
levy which she's going to cut will only
take 150 pounds off her monthly bills so
she couldn't didn't seem to be able to
answer this question i mean is enough i
think she answered it very well
so remember
what she said
the big risk to this economy is a
recession a really damaging recession
and what happens in the recession is
that businesses go bust
uh unemployment goes up and growth
uh craters so that means there's a huge
risk to jobs huge risk uh to people
being able to earn a living
and that situation is going to be
disastrous for all of us and that's why
what liz is saying is that we can't
simply continue uh on the path that
we're on we can't simply pretend that
more of the same is gonna work because
it frankly isn't okay so that's looking
to the future and we can argue about the
rights and wrongs of that but for people
like selena right now there's a real
need what's the immediate help that
people like her are going to get from a
liz cross government so i'm not going to
prejudge what a future chance is going
to say in a month or what the whoever
the prime minister is and you're just
laying out all the people i can't i i
can't say because as you say it's an
immediate ask liz has said there's got
to be an emergency budget i think she's
the only one of the candidates who said
uh there'll be an emergency budget and
in that emergency budget i'm sure
there'll be immediate relief and
actually the way that liz is talking
about the economy is we need immediate
support now that's why she's talking
about tax cuts that's why she's talking
about
allowing people to keep more of their of
their hard-earned uh money uh the rishi
plan was for a tax cut at the end of the
next parliament which is 2029. that
isn't going to cut it that isn't going
to help people like selena who have
faced immediate uh immediate uh urgent
problems well you'd agree wouldn't you
that inflation is the big problem here i
mean the bank of england's saying it's
going to reach as high as 13 by the end
of the year and you will also know that
there are a lot of economists who are
very concerned about tax cut cutting
plans in this kind of scenario they
worry they're going to be even more
inflationary and we'll end up with so no
economist i've ever heard of says the
way to deal with the recession is to put
up interest rates and to squeeze uh what
they call fiscal policy to put up taxes
so if you're facing a recession to face
a world where your interest rates are
going up and then you're putting taxes
up on top of that it is not helping uh
growth i mean that's obvious people no
economist is arguing for that well can
you explain to me why the government
says that that matching pay to inflation
is itself inflationary because it puts
more money in people's pockets why
cutting taxes doesn't have the same
effect because it puts more money in
people's pockets so i have never um
believed that the way to deal with the
recession when you're putting up
interest rates interest rates went up
yesterday by the largest amount since
1995. that's 27 years ago so on top of
that to put up taxes on people i think
is perverse it's not a way to deal uh
with a recession how do you think liz
trust got on last night i think she did
well in the program the audience seemed
to to favor richard i think she was was
very fluent he was very slick he
performed at the end
um and uh i think he did make an impact
but i think what he said which was
essentially more of the same we've got
we taxes are at a 70-year high but i'm
going to put them up and he didn't say
that but that was the implication of
what he said i think it's completely the
wrong approach and that's why i think
it's very important that liz uh wins so
that we can actually have a different
approach more of the same
uh it's not it's not going to work
any lessons learned for liz truss's team
um after last night anything that you do
differently next time if she was in a a
one-to-one uh interview or debate well
i've always felt uh that it's always
good to come uh second because that's
the you the impression that you leave uh
but that's that was due to a coin toss
you mean you mean timing-wise
timing-wise yeah she won the coin i know
i know and she she went first um but uh
but i that that was the only thing i
thought i thought she gave a very good
account of herself and she made a clear
point which i think a lot of viewers
certainly at home uh recognize is that
we cannot simply carry on as before we
can't deal with a recession by putting
up people's taxes to a 70-year high that
doesn't make any sense at all okay quasi
quatting we appreciate your time this
morning thanks very much indeed for
coming in thank you
now the edinburgh fringe festival has
had a tough couple of years it was
cancelled in 2020 because of the
pandemic and downsized last year due to
covert restrictions but it's finally
back and the first events are kicking
off today
and our arts and entertainment
correspondent katie spencer is in
edinburgh for us this morning and casey
there must be a pretty excited mood
there in edinburgh they've they've
missed their friends festival for a
couple of years so and now it's back
yeah they have definitely missed it here
i mean you wouldn't tell on the royal
mile at this time of day but actually
things are feeling like they are back to
normal after very scaled down event last
year things things are returning to how
they were and i'm joined we've managed
to drag a comedian out of bed at this
time of hour which isn't an easy thing
ola falafel you joining us now here on
the royal mile how are you feeling about
the fact that the fringe is back to
normal oh i'm i'm really pleased the
fringe bites no i'm not so pleased that
i'm woken up at this time of morning but
no it's great it's good fun i had my
first show yesterday
you're a busy man you're doing two shows
like a kid's show and an adult i'm doing
a kid show mainly because i have a book
which i'm not allowed to plug but there
is it's called trixie pickle out
avengers so i'm getting kids to draw
bum-faced snails because you are both
artist and comedian we should say and a
man of many pockets show us your flyers
hold on a second let me get these out of
the back pocket there so my show is
called stoat
and i always like to do a little
animated fire so i don't know if you can
see on the back there it's a flick book
of two dancing dung beetles and a
bouncing ball of dung
for no reason other than it amuses me
now we have to say you're very coyly
saying you don't can't possibly remember
your 2019 joke of the year that you won
last time the fringe was at its height
come on what was the joke that you
wanted it was i keep randomly shouting
out broccoli and cauliflower
i think i might have florets
i love it very good
so you've had your first few shows yeah
how's the general vibe been are people
excited to to be here it's always a slow
start but i had a great kids show in the
morning and then followed up by a
smaller than usual audience for the
adult one but it was still really good
fun and we we managed to i don't know if
you've heard i levitate a strawberry
during my act so we managed to do that i
mean you you happen to have a packet of
strawberries yeah don't you you have
promised that you can almost like plant
i mean it's it's not magic it's all down
to lung power i've got a special
strawberry levitating pipe here and you
have to go there you have to kind of get
a really fresh strawberry pop it on
there and then
breathe
oh there we go i mean it's much better
than that in my show but
i mean where else anna jones do you get
a levitating strawberry but here here in
edinburgh i have to say aren't you
pleased that the fringe is back
i've got loads of them here in the
studio actually i'll i'll have you know
katie
she judges way too quickly
anyway
have fun and we'll check in with you
again a little bit later on katie
spencer there in edinburgh thanks very
much indeed
now let's find out what some of the
younger tory party members thought about
last night's leadership program
joining me now is the youngest tory
councillor in the country harrison
allman verti and the chairman of
hartford and stalford young
conservatives bailey nash gardner so
very good morning to both of you thanks
so much for
being with us we do appreciate it so
first of all i want to hear
how you felt um it went last night for
the people that you're backing harrison
you're a rishi sunak supporter so how do
you feel that your man did
i think we should do really well last
night it was uh great to see him in
action and it was also great to that
reflected uh in the audience towards the
end is overwhelming support uh so i'm
glad that uh came through with with the
audience and uh i think he just oozed uh
competency and confidence and uh i'm
confident that the more time that goes
on uh rishi will do better
so competency and confidence from rishi
sunak
bayley do you agree with that i mean the
audience at the end did seem to back him
do you think that it was a good night
for rishi sunako for your candidate this
trust uh i mean i i feel like rishi is a
more slick than liz i feel like you know
he's sort of polished his uh
character and so you know when he's on
the tv screen he's you know a bit more
presentable you know he puts his point
across much better um you know but liz
is improving as time goes on and i'm
sure you know if she's elected uh she'll
have a great team around her to help her
you know build up that skill that rishi
has so that she'll be able to do it just
as well
and harrison
there was a lot of support for rishi
sonaka as we just said in that audience
what do you think particularly he was
tapping into there
i think
the biggest enemy that rishi sinek has
his time i think the the more uh time
that goes on i think more he will get
comfortable within raw i think more
people will um you know
like him really and so i think
for him it's more just how we can get
his point across and uh and because i i
think initially when people heard about
liz truster's initial tax cuts
people thought oh that sounds great but
i think when they hear uh liz um sorry
richie sue next plan uh and it's kind of
resonating with them a little bit more
and and they think it's a you know
more proper so i i think as more time
goes on like i mentioned before um i i
think that'll do better for him
yes and it's interesting to see how much
time he has got obviously he's got a few
more weeks while people have their
balance but they may be voting straight
away so it's difficult to know whether
he's got time on his side or not and
bailey liz trusts um was was questioned
quite hard about this regional pay
boards idea that she had had she said
she's not going ahead with it but she
wouldn't apologize
for what went on she she
continued to say that she it had been
misrepresented do you think she handled
that well how do you think she came
across with that
i think throughout the uh
whole debate you know she had some
pretty hard questions you know
particularly on the
uh topics of a her u-turn on the
regional pay and obviously i think it
was um the teacher was arguing that he
felt quite insulted but i think overall
she handled that sort of question line
of questioning pretty well you know
stood her ground that you know it was a
policy idea it was misinterpreted and so
she decided to no longer continue with
it
so you felt she handled that reasonably
well harrison what about this issue of
of rishi sunak and loyalty towards boris
johnson there was one audience member
who took issue with him in particular
saying he'd stabbed him in the back
i mean
is that going to be a problem as time
goes on there are a number of
conservative members who feel very
strongly about this that he he let down
his boss
well look he he was one of boris's
closest allies and it got to a point
where uh he thought enough was enough it
came to more morals and uh i think to
him so i think although it got a little
bit i guess you could say a bit grizzly
towards the end i think it was down to
rishi tsunakana's not really thinking
politically but thinking about himself
and his own morals and how he would act
and i think it's clear that he wouldn't
have
done the things that boris did um
so i think it was him almost showing to
the public and there's no way really of
displaying that until you actually put
your money where your mouth is and just
you know give up the job so
unfortunately that's that's where we
were um but um so yeah and that's and
that's how it happened but you know
going back to kind of what you just
mentioned there and because like i said
i think rishi performed really well
yesterday and i think when it came to
the talking about the pay board
yesterday um i i i don't think liz
answered that question very well i
thought she should have just put her
hands up said that she got it wrong
because she did i thought it was quite
insulting especially after a pandemic to
you know nurses teachers doctors and to
even have a thought of having some sort
of pay cut is is what must be really
distressing for them especially across
the living crisis